[Musique]
les topinambours et les salsifis des
légumes méconnus sont à la fois
succulent et différente de ce que nous
consommons tous les jours c'est un
légume qui viennent d'amérique on a
longtemps cru que c'est un légume qui
venaient du québec
or ce légume qui vient des états unis
que les autochtones connaissait qu'ils
vont implanter ici et c'est champlain
qui va le faire découvrir en europe qui
sera le premier en 1605
au début on n'a pas le choix pour
vaincre la faim donc on adopte certains
aliments autochtone mais très rapidement
l'alimentation des colons français
deviennent résolument française donc le
topinambour va perdre en popularité
s'étonner d'une tige dont le tubercule
porte aussi le nom de truffes du canada
prix artichauts de jérusalem
c'est que la plante lafleur ressemble à
celle du tournesol et en italie on
appelle s'agira sol alors les églises
ont entendu du rsa lyon dj ressens tu
ressembles jérusalem alors il fait ça
l'artisan de jérusalem mais qui achète
ça c'est les épiceries ou les
restaurateurs sont directement notre
connexion audio ces produits sont
cultivés en petits volumes
ils sont par le fait même plus difficile
à trouver ça fait des bols floch onga
les plafonds belle faut quelqu'un qui
gèle à brailler maillard qu'est ce que
vous allez me donner comme conseils
comment vous allez me dire d'apprêter
s'effectue comme les potable même chose
même chose des pâtes à effectuer c'est
un homme élégant préféré pour le chef
fehmi benabed le topinambour a toujours
eu sa place en cuisine
au maroc on utilise beaucoup le
topinambour puis on l'appelle pas très
bien c'est comme est ce que c'est ça
s'appelle qui m'a mal l'utilisent aussi
énormément dans les tajines les
techniques de cuisson utilisés font
varier sa texture cru il va être très
creux quand il va être
assez gorgé d'eau contrairement à une
fois cuit par exemple au four rôti alors
il est comment peut en purée en
intérieur comme un peu une pomme de
terre s'en est une pomme de terre un
petit goût artichauts petit goût en même
temps un peu un peu letter ceni benabed
nous concocte une soupe dans laquelle il
intègre des lardons
pour ajouter une touche de folie elle
sera garni de ses fleurs en plus des
topinambours qu'ils sont cuits ils
utilisent une déclinaison de ce légume
cru et encensent
[Musique]
il nous a également préparé un dessert
de bingo
c'est quoi la différence entre le
salsifis noir de sa cible le programme
toujours plus le blanc il fait plus
délicate il nettoie ses quatre tours de
la fin de la file bien ils tâchent blair
s'attachent les maires le celle ci lui
est une plante appartenant à la famille
des astéracées comme le topinambour
il est peu cultivés au québec et qu'on
fasse on n'avance plus lent que la
commission n'allait pas pourquoi ça se
vend pas mais m'ont dit qu'on n'était
pas sûr d'y associer des berges les
belges achètent la noyade paul blanc qui
mangent du salsifis au québec c'est très
rare on a essayé de l'implanter au début
du régime français
on sait que c'est du salsifis noir qu'on
a implanté ici surtout dans des jarres
des deux communautés religieuses mais
sans plus en réalité on devrait
l'appeler scorsonère plutôt que celle-ci
fille noire et il n'est disponible qu'à
l'automne dans une approche plus
locavore on recommence à l'utiliser dans
nos cuisines comme on utilise le panais
ou la carotte
c'est comme un peu le panais samson son
petit côté in peace on veut les peluches
et comme une carotte salle oxydes très
rapidement comme un peu une pomme quand
la chèvre devenir dur parce qu'elle va
oxydé on sait avec lang et fumé mangue
et de kamouraska
on prend le sel suffit on veut la voir
en purée on va l'avoir retirée on va la
voir aussi cru et voilà on commence par
quoi ça me bats je pense aux vacances et
par la soupe
cette soupe et soyeuse et la présence de
lardons révèle une petite explosion de
saveurs à chaque bouchée l'anguille
fumée accompagnée de celle ci fuit en
purée rôti et cru nous permet d'en
apprécier les différentes textures mais
qui aurait cru que le topinambour
pouvait être servis en crème glacée
c'est de toute beauté comme sauveteurs
espèrent presqu'une noiraigue
[Musique]
c'est réussi ah oui non vraiment avec le
mariage de ce créneau
bon ben vous allez peut-être nous
convaincre de s'attaquer aux
topinambours et celle ci merci beaucoup
ça me fait plaisir c'est à doigts
[Musique]